what do you do when you can't just
settle for one man you have to have many
many men today I'm gonna teach you how
to cheat and get away with it
yo you build that bridge and you crossed
it because you what no oh it's like I
don't even know where to start this is
so dumb I don't even know where to start
and the more we listen to it the more
dumb chick ensues sometimes we have to
indulge in the darker side of life right
because I know you guys are tired of
getting manipulated I hear it all the
time you're tired of getting cheated on
you tired of getting jacked well you
know what the solution is time to Jack
others so we break the cycle of jacking
it really doesn't it's not because you
cheat on somebody else that you don't
get cheated on but whatever it's like I
feel like it's a John Legend song we're
just hurt people we just hurting
everyday know are not ordinary people
yeah your brain just fabricated it I
don't know where sometimes people are
just not great at monogamy they're weak
don't they need a [ __ ] ton of attention
they have a flaccid ego they have poor
coping mechanisms from being alone being
bored being stressed whatever and
sometimes people cheat to get your
attention so if people fall into the
first category poor coping skills all
that that can be changed it can you can
work on that you know if you're cheating
to like stick it to your partner that's
bad but today we're not gonna talk about
people cheating on us sorry
we're gonna talk about cheating on them
but I bring all this up because look if
you're cheating to hurt your partner
just leave girl literally just leave
just leave because ostensibly
you want to cheat and like not get
caught but if you wanted cheat and get
caught on purpose
you're gonna play yourself because then
you're the bad guy so let's say your
boyfriend is a shitbird and you really
have legitimate reasons for getting
revenge on him and like sticking it to
him if you go out and take up the mantle
of the villain you blow your position
you blow the only leverage you have and
victim mentality you know we talked
about that usually on this channel we're
talking about good things and positivity
about how toxic victim mentality isn't
how much it sucks and how annoying it is
they are so fixated on their past and
how they were like mistreated and nobody
liked them when they were 13 I've got
news for you guys
no one likes anyone when they're 13 so
it bothers me when guys have this like
wounded victim mentality victim
mentality you know we talk about that
usually on this channel we're talking
about good things and positivity about
our toxic victim mentality isn't how
much it sucks and how annoying it is for
everyone around you but it's really
useful when your boyfriend sucks you
know you have to hang on to that victim
narrative that's your power and not your
leverage okay it's a wrap this is okay
I'm going I mean we're good let's do the
rest of this video in the dark yeah
because we're talk about the dark side
of things
what's all right so here's what's wrong
every now and then I get asked to react
to a video that's so goddamn done it
breaks my brain and I don't even know if
it's what I've already started filming
so I can't stop because I've already
suffered I might as well go all the way
wrap this up you will be able to read
this out is really dumb it's really dumb
yeah don't go out there to make yourself
be a villain by getting caught basically
be a really good villain by doing it
behind their backs and never letting
them know and one of the first things
she said is you know you're tired of
being manipulated and what should resort
doing Maggie I wish I had something very
insightful for you guys but the reality
is if you want to cheat just leave
regardless of whether you want to hurt
the person or not hurt the person just
don't be the monogamous relationship
there's so many people out here there's
so many apps for you to hook up on don't
try to have your cake and eat it too if
you want to be someone who walks through
life with integrity with a set of values
that are worth having don't engage in
behavior that's really despicable you
know she talks about manipulating others
right
because you're tired of getting
manipulated you don't fix the hurt that
you have by hurting other people you
don't build self-esteem by tearing other
people down fit the rules with your
partner and if you cross the rules whoa
that's leave so if you wanna think
there's a hierarchy to evilness I mean
sure there's definitely things where
intent makes something more worse but
the end of the day not only give you
guys a tutorial on how to be a bad
person I'm not gonna give you a tutorial
on how to be petty how to fraud let's do
one on how to fry you know what I mean
if you fraud because it's this person
but you do for evil reasons but don't
try to imagine if you fraud to give back
it's good not been hood maybe it's not
an ordinary thing that she does maybe
because it's Halloween it's like doing
evil things cuz I'll give you 212 but I
just don't know why you'd want to put
stuff like that out there have you seen
the rest of her videos yeah yeah it just
was kind of weird to watch
I made uncomfortable to be honest with
you it made you come from what made you
uncomfortable I just just it's just a
comfort level so huh that's the only
it's just a comfort level with which she
said her ideas and she seems like an
introspective person to a degree but I
didn't realize if she had the
self-awareness to realize how people
were reacting why what she's saying is
so bad well we already established the
fact that previous video that because of
her looks she was allowed to do a lot of
things you know the looks I think the
looks factor and how she perceived
herself out there makes her acts in a
way because she's allowed to because I
don't know if you see how
she's talking there's always a good
reason for her to doing the stuff that
she did mmm nice that's it for today's
video I have nothing more insightful to
add leave your comments below do you
guys want to learn how to cheat and so
be sure to check out our video be sure
to check down the video that's all you
got to shout her out hey if you wanna
cheat at the end of the day if you want
to cheat
[Music]